[Applaus]
so stehen sie auch immer noch unter
Schock Deutschland war mal der Streber
Europas me wir haben dem ganzen
Kontinent erklärt wie Haushalten geht
und jetzt das vielen Dank Ampel voll
Blamage ehrlich mindestens 60 Milliarden
die sie in Wirklichkeit nie hatten sind
jetzt offiziell futsch die Beratung zum
Haushalt 24 wurden verschoben und für 23
wird jetzt doch wieder die
Schuldenbremse ausgesetzt nächste
Notlage hat Christian Lindner gestern
verkündet ohne Schuldenbremse aussetzen
zu sagen weil davon kriegt er Pickel
glaube ich
ja diese Woche und jetzt kommt der
Hammer diese Woche wurde die
italienische Ministerpräsidentin beim
Besuch in Deutschland in Berlin gefragt
ob wir noch ein seriöser Partner sind
und jetzt achten Sie mal auf die für
seine Verhältnisse völlig eskalierende
Mimik von Olaf Scholz ist Deutschland
aus italienischer Sicht noch
diesbezüglich ein verlässlicher
Partner ja Wahnsinn oder so Freunde das
hier ist der Beweis für den
Ausnahmezustand in Olaf Scholz Gesicht
bewegt sich was Wahnsinn ja meine die
Ampel und jetzt kommen wir zum
erschütternden Teil die Ampel hat immer
noch keinen Plan B Steuern erhöhen ist
nicht Schuldenbremse dauerhaft
reformieren will Lindner auch nicht
heißt neue kreative Wege der
Geldbeschaffung sind plötzlich gefragt
welche auch
immer z.B na diese eine Sache sie wissen
schon die wir noch nie ernsthaft
versucht haben wie heißt das noch sparen
genau ja so leider wissen die aber nicht
mal wie viel Geld ihnen fehlt denn
betroffen ist neben dem
klimatransformationsfond kurz KTF auch
der WSF Abkürzung für what the [__] nee
nein nein für
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond wie zum
Henker konnte das passieren sie haben
sich zusammengesetzt und haben gesagt
die SPD kriegt viel Geld für Soziales
die Grünen kriegen viel Geld für Klima
und die FDP kriegt zwei Zusagen nämlich
es gibt keine Steuererhöhung und die
Schuldenbremse wird eingehalten und dann
haben Sie gemerkt oh Kacke wir haben
nicht genug Geld
so ja oh Kacke wir haben nicht genug
Geld so heißt übrigens auch die neue
Autobiografie von Boris Becker
aber diese Ampel kann aber nicht nur
wahsin Kacke rechnen ihr fehlt jede
Selbstkritik tagelang kein sorry nicht
meine Erklärung wie sie das von ihnen
verursachte Chaos zu beseitigen gedenken
bis heute Nachmittag war der Kanzler
wieder mal sie ahenes richtig unsichtbar
meine Damen und Herren ja was
sonst sein Umfeld wird zitiert mit wenn
er unter Druck ist wird Olaf Scholz ganz
ruhig also noch ruhiger oder wie ja war
jetzt auch Thema in der neuen Folge
von Expeditionen ins
regierreich das Scholz ein porierlicher
kanzlergeselle mit einer besonderen
Fähigkeit bei Gefahr oder wenn ihm
plötzlich 60 Milliarden fehlen wird es
ganz ruhig der Körper des Scholz stellt
alle nicht lebensnotwendigen Funktionen
ein Milz Ellbogen und weiteteile des
Großhirns werden nicht mehr durchblutet
seine Mimik zeigt dann absolute Lehre
also wie immer eigentlich steigt der
Druck noch weiter stellt sich der Scholz
einfach tot eine verbreitete Strategie
im Tierreich wie diese Ziege
beweist ja wir haben ja auch einen
Bildungsauftrag meine Damen und Herren
so heute hat er endlich in einer
Videobotschaft zum Volk gesprochen 2
Minuten 48 es tut mir so leid dass ich
die geguckt habe meine Damen und Herren
ja nur Allgemeinplätze wieder kein Wort
des Bedauerns keine Antworten dafür
Fragen unser oberstes Gericht hat
vergangene Woche ein Grundsatzurteil zur
Schuldenbremse
verkündet sie fragen sich was bedeutet
diese Entscheidung für mich konkret oder
wie ist es um unsere Staatsfinanzen
bestellt ja
scheiße vielen Dank das wusste ich schon
so Scholz Botschaft ansonsten keine
Panik Leute der fati hat längst den
nächsten masterplat im Köcher ja
unerschütterliche Arroganz nicht zu
fassen ähnlich deprimierend leider die
Rolle der der Opposition statt ja
vielleicht mal konstruktive Vorschläge
zu machen wie man aus dem schlimassel
rauskommen könnte nur Häme und Gemecker
märz und dobrin kriegen jetzt sogar
eigene Figuren in der mappetshow hoch
verdient ja ist aber ein klassisches
Eigentor denn auch in CDU geführten
Ländern liegen ja noch diverse
Sondervermögen rum der März ist nur noch
im
angebermodus sogar wenn er vor
unschuldigen Kindern redet welche
Aufgabe ich in der Partei habe
Vorsitzender dieser Partei
also der Chef in ganz Deutschland wir
haben 400 000
Mitglieder nicht schlecht oder ja nicht
schlecht oder Chef in ganz Deutschland
ne hat dein Vater auch ein eigenes
Flugzeug nee ne siehst du so alles was
von März kommt ist Sozialleistung kürzen
aber selbst wenn man
Kindergrundsicherung bürgergelderhöhung
und heizungsgesetz streichen würde das
waren ja Fritzes erste sagen wir mal
Ideen wer das ein Bruchteil der Summe
die fehlt wie stopfen wir also das
gigantische Haushaltsloch wie so die
große Mehrheit der Ökonomen die Mehrzahl
der Ökonomen sagt der nötige Umbau
unserer Wirtschaft lässt sich mit Sparen
allein nicht finanzieren entweder es
gibt einen Sondervermögen fürs Klima
also wie bei der Bundeswehr oder wir
reformieren die Schuldenbremse und
nehmen öffentliche Investitionen endlich
raus deutschland hat mit Abstand die
niedrigste Schuldenquote aller
Industrienationen gleichzeitig
vergammelt aber unser Schienennetz warum
wirklich und so dessen dessen
versprochene Sanierung ist leider auch
akut gefährdet durch das Urteil aus
karsruhe als als wärden die Bahnkunden
nicht schon genug gestraft zwischen all
den Streiks die Bahnkunden zwischen
Unverständnis und Resignation ich fahre
seit 10 Jahren bahen das innerlich alles
tot da fühlt man gar nichts
mehr
ja okay
das wäre doch ein super Slogan für die
Deutsche Bahn da fühlt man gar nichts
mehr solche Investitionen hier
verschieben macht es am Ende nur noch
teurer wann lernen wir das endlich
angesagt wäre Schuldenbremse reformieren
und sparen ja auch im sozialen
mütterrente Rente mit 63 Weg warum
kriegen wohlhabende Geld für Wärmepumpen
oder
e-autoladestation allein die Abschaffung
des dieselprivilegs brechte über 8
Milliarden will sagen zumindest
ernsthafte sp bemüh müssen schon sein
einfach nur immer neue Notlagen ausrufen
reicht nicht und wenn doch gilt das
demnächst für alle auch im
Privatleben lass no mal wieder Luft raus
Zahl endlich mal deinen Deckel da sind
über 300 €
offen wenn das so ist dann erklre ich
jetzt meine akute Notlage für mein
Haushalt Ukraine und so keine
Ahnung und jetzt mach voll du Arschloch
Scheiße Artikel 109 da steht hier
wirklich
sie Lokalrunde für
[Applaus]
alle wenn dann GT das für
alle so Preisfrage was wäre jetzt
richtig wirklich tabulos sparen um es
mal sexy auszudrücken oder ist das dann
doch die gefürchtete
modernisierungsbremse reden wir drüber
mit dem sexy Buchprüfer der heute Show
mit Olaf Schubert Olaf schön dass du da
bist deine Einschätzung was ist
schlimmer den Kindern Schulden zu
hinterlassen oder eine kaputte
Infrastruktur ich bin da verhalten
optimistisch denn vielleicht schaffen
wir ja beides ja also ich finde jetzt
bloß kaputte Infrastruktur wäre ein
bisschen dürftig ich bin der Meinung
Schulden gehören dazu ja die können wir
dann der nächsten Generation zur
Verfügung stellen äh kostenlos quasi
als stadtkapital ja da haben die
Jugendlichen dann was Eigenes das ist
dann quasi ihr Jodeldiplom und und wenn
man quasi in die Kinder investiert das
ist ja keine einbandstraße ja man
bekommt ja etwas zurück ich meine die
Kinder haben natürlich noch kein Geld ja
aber die machen es auf ihre Art die
basteln was die schenken etwas mit ganz
viel Liebe mit ganz viel Hingebung und
dann finde ich es auch wichtig dass man
dann als Erwachsener sagt das reicht
nicht ja
also das ist zu wenig und ich glaube im
Endeffekt wissen ja alle Infrastruktur
ist überbewertet ich glaube wenn wir
wollen dann kommen wir hier auch ohne
Industrie klar wenn wir den
Strukturwandel gestalten lebendig machen
wenn wir die Chancen nutzen ja wie eben
z.B den
Tretbootverleih ja also wenn man das
richtig fett aufzieht wenn du das ganz
da kannst du krass rasieren das ballert
brutal ja jetzt bist du ja wie man hört
kreativer Typ fallen dir noch andere
geldbeschaffungsideen für die Ampel ein
ja Geld also natürlich man kann immer
irgendwas sage ich mal als erstes
irgendwas verhökern irgendwas
verschärbeln was man nicht mehr braucht
was weiß ich
SachsenAnhalt so das kann man jetzt
natürlich nicht einfach bei ebay
reinstellen klar aber im Darknet ja also
ich habe gehört Preise bis 5 € pro
Hektar ja also da käme was zusammen dann
z.B für ebay wäre natürlich bbox
regierungsflieger ja also da kriegt man
bestimmt
auch 12,90 € sage ich mal wenn man
vorher noch mal general überholt ja und
unsere kabinetsmitglieder haben
natürlich auch alle verborgene Talente
also man kann Kanzler Scholz quasi jetzt
mieten für
[Applaus]
Kindergeburtstage mehr wird's
nicht mehr wird's nicht da hat er auch
gleich ein Slogan für das nächste
Wahlplakat
aber wir müssen uns schon im klar sein
wir brauchen natürlich große Beträge und
dann müssen wir ehrlich sein da gibt's
dann nur zwei Varianten also entweder
Steuererhöhung ja oder ja wir müssen
dann halt eben wirklich in die Schweiz
einmarschieren
ich denke das ist der unkompliziertere
Weg ja also
vorsichtig einmarschieren ja also
achtsam nachhaltig und auch nur in den
deutschsprachigen Teil wobei das ist
egal man versteht die auch nicht aber in
jeden Fall in der Schweiz liegt ja
Schotter kiesasche die haben ja Geld ja
also Deutschland das ist das ist für die
Dritte Welt ja also für die Schweizer
für die sind wir ja
edelkanacken
ja ja gute Idee Union und FDP möchten
stattdessen Sozialleistungen kürzen
tatsächlich ist das ja der größte Kosten
im Bundeshaushalt
40% fast 40 des Haushalts gehen in
Bürgergeld Kindergrundsicherung Rente
etc wie viel Potenzial siehst du im
sozialen Bereich
40% ja das ist fast ein Drittel ja
also aber ich denke da sind wir uns
einig also bei
Sozialleistungen kann man nicht kürzen
und deshalb würde ich die komplett
abschaffen ja also na ja also natürlich
sozialverträglich gest ja erst die
Ärmsten
und na ja ich meine ich sag mal so also
selbst der schwächste wird noch
durchgefüttert ja also das das ist auch
so diese ostmentalität ja ich meine
damit muss man ja irgendwann mal
aufhören dass ist ja irgendwie voll 80er
und und und wenn wir jetzt sparen ja
dann findet er vielleicht alles noch ein
versöhnliches Ende irgendwie in 70
Jahren dann ist sowieso Klimawandel dann
ist alles überflutet ja dann schippern
die da drum auf dem Floß und dann sagen
die vielleicht na ja halb so wild
wenigstens hatten die damals eine
schwarze Null OL Schuber vielen
Dank Schuber so meine Damen und Herren
es ist wirklich die Frage aller Fragen
wo sparen wir jetzt ganz einfach beim
Bürgergeld bei den faulen tönt es aus
Boulevard und Union ja das Bürgergeld
steigt im Januar um 12% und deshalb sagt
sich jetzt sogar Bob der baumn Meister
warte mal 61 € mehr im Monat ich h heute
noch aufzubauen und werde Bob der
bürgergeldempfänger tatsächlich zu den
Fakten wird ab 2024 die Inflation
schneller in die Regelsätze einberechnet
und zwar auf Ansage des
Verfassungsgerichtes weshalb man da auch
gar nicht ohne weiteres kürzen darf ja
na und wer redet schon über langweilige
Tatsachen wenn auch Stimmung machen kann
die Menschen gehen nicht zurück in die
Beschäftigung weil sie sich ausrechnen
können dass sie mit staatlichen
Transferleistungen am Ende des Jahres
mehr herausbekommen als wenn sie in
einer einfachen Beschäftigung arbeiten
und Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und
Steuern bezahlen
müssen ja wie drücke ich das jetzt
höflich aus was wir gerade gehört haben
liebe Kinder entspricht nicht ganz der
Wahrheit
ja warte
mal so tatsächlich findet die behauptete
Massenflucht aus Arbeit in Bürgergeld
nicht statt die Zahl der Menschen die
aus einer Beschäftigung in
Grundsicherung wechseln ist so niedrig
wie noch nie die ist seit Einführung des
Bürgergelds sogar gesunken sagt die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit könnte sein
dass die sich mit Arbeit auskennen ja
und auch das mit dem wer arbeitet hat
weniger wird nicht wahrer wenn man
ständig
wiederholt alleinstehende
bürgergeldbezieher haben demnach 966 €
ein vollzeitarbeitender mit Mindestlohn
1498 € ein Unterschied von 532 € ja gut
der Vergleich hingt ich meine das rechts
im Bild ist ja auch ein Mann der muss ja
mehr
verdienen so und auch bei einer
vierköpfigen Familie sind es immer noch
mindestens 405 € mehr selbst wenn nur
ein Elternteil zum Mindestlohn arbeitet
so viel zur von der Bildzeitung
behaupteten
bürgergeldbadewanne was aber stimmt der
Niedriglohnsektor ist bei uns seit
Jahren nicht attraktiv genug trotzdem
fordert kein ominenter Unionspolitiker
den Mindestlohn zu erhöhen man ist ja
nur so allgemein für die fleißigen die
die früh aufstehen das mit dem Aufstehen
ist den ohnehin super wichtig da wird
ein völlig falsches Signal gesetzt dann
die Leute jeden Tag aufstehen hart
arbeiten mehr herauszubekommen als wenn
man morgens um 7 Uhr aufsteht jeden
Morgen aufstehen und schuften gehen die
morgens um 7 Uhr hier im hochsaurand
morgens um 7 Uhr aufstehen und sich die
Frage stellen warum stehe ich elich
auf ja sag mal so im hochsaurerland
würde ich mich das auch morgen
Fragen und zwar direkt nach warum wohne
ich eigentlich
hier Spaß so Harz 4 wissen sie Harz 4
war ja vor allem eine Drohkulisse man
wollte damit Menschen zwingen jeden Job
anzunehmen sogar in der Gebäudereinigung
wo bis heute in Wirklichkeit oft nicht
mal Mindestlohn gezahlt wird mit
gewissen Tricks märz und sein geistiger
Klon lindnemann machen sich also zu
Lobbyisten der Ausbeuter ja er hier
fordert sogar Zwangsarbeit für bürgerg
Geldempfänger wer nach 6 Monaten immer
noch keinen Job hat müsste dann
gemeinnützig arbeiten was ist das für
ein beklopptes Menschenbild nur 3% der
bürgergeld/hzempfänger müssen
sanktioniert werden ich finde die Union
soll mal zum Therapeuten gehen mit ihrem
komischen
bestrafungsfetisch ist doch krank
wirklich
jetzt ist do nicht normal ne außerdem
Leute wenn bestrafen dann aber richtig
ne so wie damals es war nicht alles
schlecht Berlin ze Jugendliche
arbeitsbumelanten sind im Stadtbezirk
friedrichsein von einer Kommission für
gesellschaftliche Erziehung öffentlich
zur Rechenschaft gezogen worden gegen
die Jugendlichen die keiner geregelten
Arbeit nachgingen und auch ihre Miete
nicht bezahlten wurde Arbeitserziehung
beantragt ja so hätten wir das
Bürgergeld nennen müssen
arbeitsbumelandengeld ja
bürgergeldempfänger dürfen sich auf
keinen Fall so die Botschaft der Union
als vollwertige Bürger fühlen das geht
doch nicht so
und und ja und wenn es jetzt immer heißt
5 Millionen von denen wollen nicht
arbeiten rund 1 Million arbeiten die
müssen aber aufstocken weil ihr
sogenannter Lohn nicht zum Leben reicht
wieder andere sind allein erziehend oder
pflegen Verwandte unterm Strich bleiben
1,6 Millionen erwerbsfähige Arbeitslose
darunter aber nicht wenige die nur
befristete saisonjobs haben und sich
zwischendurch mit Bürgergeld über Wasser
halten müssen warum trotzdem das
permanente Gehetze gegen faule Arme weal
es Quote bringt jetzt bei Deutschlands
frechste bürgergeldschnorrer der Fall
Melanie B aus Braunschweig sie lebt
immer noch bei ihrer Mutter die auch den
ganzen Tag nur faul im Bett sitzt die
dreisten Abzocker nennen es häusliche
Pflege oder der notorisch faule Marvin S
aus Duisburg dessen kinderabends in der
bürgergeldbadewanne chillen seine
Ausrede allein erziehend W glaubt und
natürlich dieser völlig skrupulose
frührendner der mit russischem
Bürgergeld aufstockt zum
Kotzen ja sowas läuft ja rund um die Uhr
beil2 so reden wir doch vielleicht mal
über echte Probleme z.B das idiotische
nebeneinander und sich überlappen von
Sozialleistung die nicht alle so richtig
zu Ende gedacht sind wie das Wohngeld ja
kriegt man einem bestimmten Einkommen
statt Bürgergeld und dann wird aber das
Einkommen auf Wohngeld und
Kinderzuschlag angerechnet sodass man
kein Witz im Worst Case bei einer
Lohnerhöhung von 1000 € brutto in
München oder Leipzig am Ende weniger hat
verstehen sie man kriegt 1000 mehr und
hat weniger wer denkt sich sowas aus und
warum Herr küne das fällt mir jetzt
wirklich nicht leicht sie arbeiten seit
14 Jahren in meiner Firma und haben
immer 100% gegeben aber so leid es mir
tut ich muss Ihnen heute eine
Gehaltserhöhung von 1000 € geben was
aber das können sie doch nicht
machen dann streichen Sie mir wenigstens
mein Weihnachtsgeld sorry aber das sind
mir die Hände gebunden bitte ich habe
Kinder hier ich ich ich klaue
Büromaterial ich komme ständig zu spät
ich bin jetzt gerade besoffen bitte
Sicherheitsdienst geben Sie küne seine
Gehaltserhöhung in
bar nein
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nein
Wohngeld
ja so wir haben mal nachgerechnet 170
verschiedene Sozialleistung gibt's
inzwischen bei uns 170 und manche
entwickeln ein Eigenleben verstehen sie
die Bürokrat spürt dass wir sie
bekämpfen und wehrt sich weniger
Bürokratie das Versprechen alle
deutschen Regierung seit ich weiß nicht
Karl dem Großen aber es klappt nie
aktuelles Beispiel die
Kindergrundsicherung ein Ampel
Vorzeigeprojekt und unser nächstes
Bürokratiemonster wir scheiden deshalb
mal live zu Albrecht Humbold
Pressesprecher der Familienministerin
der Humbold sollte die
Kindergrundsicherung nicht alles
einfacher machen ja macht sie ja auch
demnächst wenn sich das alles zurecht
geruckelt hat gucken Sie mal ich habe
hier extra einen Mitarbeiter der rund um
die Uhr Bürgerfragen zur Grundsicherung
beantwortet und da ist das Feedback
überwiegend positiv fast schon
begeistert der ist einer meiner
zufriedensten Kollegen
überhaupt klar natürlich bei jedem
Gesetz erstmal gibt's auch ein paar
Geburtswehen aber im Prinzip gilt immer
noch was unsere vpaus im Sommer
versprochen hat wir fassen alle
relevanten Leistungen für Kinder zu
einer Leistung Zusam zusammen zur
Kindergrundsicherung bis zu 5,6
Millionen armutsbedrohte Familien und
ihre Kinder bekommen dadurch die
Leistungen schneller einfacher und
direkter so und das hat auch alles super
geklappt bis auf das mit schneller
einfacher und direkter gut ein Fehler
war möglicherweise den Anschein zu
erwecken Familien bekehmen bald
automatisch Geld wenn es optimal läuft
werden die darauf hingewiesen dass Sie
einen Antrag stellen können was in der
Praxis dann allerdings einen
Informationsaustausch zwischen allen
beteiligten Behörden voraussetzt mit
neuer Technik und genug Mitarbeitern
will sagen was soll denn da bitte
schiefgen frage ich Sie was nee ich habe
da auch ein total gutes Gefühl muss ich
sagen für Eltern in Bürgergeld sind
weiter die Jobcenter zuständig für ihre
Kinder aber die neue Behörde
Familienservice so dann muss man aber
beim Jobcenter z.B die anteiligen Kosten
der Unterkunft der Kinder aus dem
Bürgergeld für die Eltern wieder
rausrechnen kuck guck ja ja sorry aber
wie soll ich denn Bürokratie abbauen
ohne mehr Bürokratie geht ja gar nicht
so statt mal dankbar zu sein für den
Familienservice wir schaffen da mal eben
tausende neue Stellen für 500 Millionen
Euro zusätzliche Verwaltungskosten pro
Jahr im Grunde super schppchen ich sag
mal in der Black Friday
Woche gut aber von den neuen Stellen
haben arme Kinder jetzt erstmal nicht so
viel und auch das versprochene digitale
chancenportal wird frühstens
2029 fertig da sind viele Kinder von
heute längst in der Midlife Crisis und
ihre Chefin wollte übrigens mal 12
Milliarden für ihre Grundsicherung
konnte aber nie erklären wofür
eigentlich na ja dazu muss man wissen
Lisa Paus hat wirklich alle möglichen
Qualitäten aber Sachen schnell auf den
Punkt bringen ist halt nicht so ihr
trotzdem ist es richtig dass
M das dort mit
das
D das dort
eben passiert ihr öfter deshalb gibt's
hier intern ja den Spruch die schönsten
Pausen sind
Lisa Wortspiel ja im Moment schlagen
mehrere Verbände Alarm weil die
Beantragung des Elterngeldes so
kompliziert geworden ist dass immer mehr
Eltern einfach aufgeben ich wusste genau
dass sie damit ankommen deshalb werde
ich jetzt hier live diesen 26 seitigen
Elterngeldantrag für Berlin ausfüllen
Baby einfach passt super weil meine Frau
und ich kriegen demnächst unser erstes
Kind und da gehe erstmal ich in
Elternzeit voll modern so was haben wir
denn hier
jeder Elternteil bekommt vier
zusätzliche
Monatsbeiträge Elterngeld plus beide
Elternteile müssen gleichzeitig in jedem
einzelnen der vier Lebensmonate zwischen
was 25 und 30 Wochenstunden im
Monatsdurchschnitt erwerbsfähig sein
umch komm leck mich
doch ja Schatz ja ich ma das nicht mit
der Elternzeit ja du bleibst doch zu
Hause weil der Fragebogen scheiße
ist ja dann zieh doch zu deiner Mutter
die hat auch nie gearbeitet Albrecht
Humbold vielen
[Applaus]
Dank nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den Kanal abonniert und
ein Like da lasst
ich habe die Schnauze
voll ja los lass ein Abo
da